my little baby Invictus is lying here
sleeping with a smile on his face and I
kiss him is ill him and I tell for I'm
sorry but I'll come for you and then I
let him have it
a few years ago Daisy Bram her partner
Jamie Walsh and their son Thor moved
from Iowa to California they made the
move in part because California is a
medical marijuana state we ended up in
Butte County just kind of happened
Stan's found a nice little mountain home
in con Cal which is like this
unincorporated little mountain town and
planted our little vegetable garden and
planning our little cannabis garden had
all our paperwork in order growing
medical marijuana is common in Northern
California especially in places like
Butte County where medical marijuana
dispensaries aren't allowed juice was
born on September 1st right there in the
bathtub I delivered him and it was great
and the Sun was shining a few weeks
after the birth of zhuzh Butte County
sheriff's showed up at brandman Walsh's
door but I'm nursing my 28 day old Zuse
and my 15 month-old door and I hear bang
bang bang bang bang they see what you're
under s4 is cultivation of marijuana and
possession of marijuana for sale and
that's another charges child
endangerment on upon yours
I forgot that you have the three okay
brandman Walsh has two young boys were
taken by Child Protective Services and
placed in foster care for four months
Daisy Bram's case is unique because
she's being charged with child
endangerment by virtue of having grown
marijuana or being present when we're
menthe marijuana was being grown Michael
Levinson an attorney who specializes in
medical marijuana cases is representing
brand pro bono I don't believe that the
numbers of plants are the ways in which
they were being grown exceed reasonable
expectations for medical use 30 some
plants that you find in the backyard if
we were really criminals when we grow
pot in our yard for everybody and their
mother to see it I don't know the CPS
case closes on us in July and
everything's just fine and Jamie and I
are just kind of living our life
September 18th comes and our third son
Invictus was born and late in 2012 with
their Butte County cases still
unresolved Bram and Walsh decided to
move to neighboring Tehama County I find
this beautiful little spread on the
river and all my goodness Jamie loves to
fish and I've got three boys I mean
could you find a better spot Orchard in
the front yard look at all this space
and it just seems too good to be true in
January of this year Tehama County
sheriff's raided Bram and Walsh's new
home this time they found a cannabis
garden in a locked room off the back of
the house there were 15 cannabis plants
about 12 inches high and so that's
they're they're all excited so they're
tearing through the house tearing
through the house and becomes very
quickly evident that work will both
going to be arrested and the kids are
going to be taken again for the second
time in less than two years
Bram and Walsh were charged with
cultivation of marijuana possession with
intent to sell and child abuse and once
again their children were taken by Child
Protective Services I don't know he's
hope that someday they can forgive me
they know I love them Balch is in jail
with bail set at 1 million dollars Bram
is out on bail and in February she went
to a family court hearing in Tehama
County as bran was leaving the
courthouse an investigator from the
District Attorney's Office approached
her car and he reaches in and turns off
the engine and says get out and I'm like
oh they're really awesome because I'm
taking the vehicle go stand over there
and I said what do you mean you're
taking the vehicle he says this this car
was purchased with the illegal sale of
narcotics I'm like what I pull out three
car seats and all my personal effects
while he's taking pictures and the
social workers and everybody's coming
out of court and I'm just mortified and
they get in the car and they leave
I highly doubt they're ever going to be
able to resell it for anything close to
what it cost them to grab it and I think
that they also knew that that was just
one thing they could do to Daisy they
could take that car and really really
turn her life into a real hassle I'm
scared of them you win I'm scared for
now
Brandon Walter in a state of limbo
awaiting future court date while their
children remain in foster care I've only
seen my children you know a total of
four hours supervised since they were
taken and every time I've seen them
they're in worse shape they were the
time before I taught them sign language
and they're forgetting all that they're
not being fed properly they're not being
closed they're not being taken care of
at all my children are so angry with me
they won't come near me they won't touch
me
they won't barely look at me they won't
use any of their signs they refuse
refuse to say mommy your mama or
anything there is just nothing worse
there's nothing worse that someone can
be accused of than doing something to
harm their own children and if someone
from the government is going to come
after someone to make that accusation
they better have the ammunition ready to
go I'd gotten the phone
all when I came out of Family Court on
Friday that they were going to move the
babies because the foster parents didn't
want them anymore they've gotten hurt
and the case was too much publicity and
high-profile and they my demands for
their care with me Oh Granite Cola stick
natural hold stuff was too much and they
just won't do anymore did I know of
anywhere they could go yeah home with
her mama
Daisy Bram has received significant
support from the Medical Marijuana
community her story is important because
it highlights a key question in the
ongoing debate surrounding Marijuana
Policy our people who grow and use
cannabis fit to be parents the
prosecution was really never able to
establish through scientific evidence
that the mere presence of raw cannabis
is dangerous to anyone's health let
alone a child I suppose to some degree
you want to make sure that everything
your children have access to is
absolutely positively ok for them then
no one should ever have alcohol or any
cleaning products or cords that kids
could trip over I mean we we live on the
Sacramento River and while it's
beautiful and great does that not
present a drowning hazard she does not
deserve to be accused of doing anything
to harm her children because she has
never done such a thing
and never would you know when you're
good at something when I'm good at being
a mother because I love it
you